Alexander Rybak, welcome!
How nice!
Hello!
When you look back at these images,
we can see that you've already had quite a long career
since your breakthrough in 2009.
And a very European career.
You've been big in many countries.
And now you're leaving Europe!
I would say I'm more Norway based.
Even though I'm now going to Chicago.
Because you are going to Chicago?
Yes I am. Okay. I am going to Chicago.
What's the deal, you're going to attend school?
Oh, Fredrik, this is a new chapter in my life! It's so much fun!
It's great fun! I'm doing a master's degree
in ... It's said to be among the top three film music schools in the world.
So I'm very privileged.
It's so much fun and I already feel like I've been given a new family.
And it's online, and then my mum will appear in the background with shrimp sandwiches!
They see love first and foremost, but I'm a bit embarrassed.
But up until now, no one's mentioned it.
You've moved within many genres, you've worked in many countries,
you've done an incredible amount of things since your breakthrough.
As I mentioned initially, this came at a price.
And with that I mean
a post that you shared in social media earlier this summer.
Which to a lot of people was very surprising, including to me.
And it was about to what degree you've been a pill addict.
And eaten too many medicines.
It started with
something that was supposed to help me with sleep. I'm a
highly sensitive person.
For instance, I considered earlier to try to act laid-back,
you look so cool when you ...
But that's not me, I'm always highly alert.
And when you're participating in the world's biggest music competition,
and you're as sensitive as me,
you end up having extreme difficulties falling asleep.
And sleep is very important when you're going to
use your voice, play the violin and in general function as a human being.
So now we're in 2009 and your breakthrough with Fairytale?
Yes.
So I got a little help with sleeping pills,
very innocent and a very small dose.
And all of a sudden, all these constant nuisances disappeared, where nothing was good enough,
that I would stop myself when speaking,
that I forgot to breathe, everything just disappeared
the last 30 minutes before I fell asleep.
And I thought, «ah, this is life»!
And then it just became more and more the following years.
When did you realise that you
had a form of addiction?
I never understood it. I never understood it.
I understood that this was something that I wanted to keep doing on a daily basis.
Preferably.
But I didn't think about abuse or addiction, I didn't think in those terms.
I just thought that I had found the pill that made me whole.
But there are a lot of people who take a sleeping pill once in a while and who
are just fine with that. But for you, that has
had a big impact, maybe also on you personality?
Yes, yes, yes. Without a doubt.
It's ...
My doctors warned me all the time.
The problem was that I had several doctors in several different countries and I
self-medicated.
I was completely sure of that fact that I needed this.
So when I didn't get any more from one doctor, I would ask the other.
It's not good.
What did it do with your personality?
When I think about it, everything
that people have heard about from the media,
where I've thrown the bow to the ground at an event on Liseberg,
where I've
yelled at a sound guy,
where I broke my hand in a wall after a sound guy ...
The incidents were not related, by the way.
So ...
I think that all this has happened in the evening.
When the last remaining part of the sleeping pill
from the day before has disappeared.
Before you've taken more?
Yes. The last two or three hours when your body is saying that «it's really about time».
And I've also noticed that with people who for instance have lived with me.
When I come home at eight in the evening,
there was just one thing that I sub-consciously was thinking about.
And that was to take your sleeping pill?
Yes.
What kind of boyfriend did you become?
I wrote a lot of nice songs.
But again ...
A healthy girl would most likely want to talk to her boyfriend.
No matter how late is is in the evening.
But I would come home from some concert at ten, and
it was very nice seeing her, but I would rather just watch a movie and ...
Because I knew how irritated I was as a person.
Have you been
open about this?
For example when it comes to your girlfriend,
did she realise
that you were doing this?
Or have you been hiding it a little?
The problem is that I haven't been open about this with myself.
That's been the biggest problem.
It was only last year that I realised this.
What about your parents, how did they react?
Well, everybody tried, but ...
It's like with most other things, that ...
There's nobody but yourself who can initiate such a difficult process
as getting rid of something that
you think is going to save you.
You decided, as far as I've understood,
to wean off this,
and you made a plan.
What did the plan look like?
It's to do with what I talked about, that you're in denial about what the root of the problem is.
So when it really began to escalate and I started to get a lot of
problems with my stomach and things like that,
after a while I couldn't walk,
daytime I started to walk like this,
which also led to back problems.
And it would be like «isn't that Alexander walking on the street like that?».
It was a little too early for that.
And I began to understand that this ...
I had to get to the bottom of this.
And I had
the premiere for my musical, last year.
And that's the biggest thing you can accomplish as a composer, to get your own musical.
With a million-kroner budget.
And it was a fantastic concert venue.
And I had to get well.
But I refused to realise that I perhaps should quit some medications.
I started touring around Europe to different doctors
and do gastroscopies and alternative doctors and lots of different things.
I spent way too much money on it.
And became completely obsessed.
And again, the most obvious thing I didn't realise until the end of last year.
And by then it was too late, I couldn't begin to both step down and
do a great part in my musical.
So then I did something completely different.
I began taking valium.
Which to me worked like sleeping pills.
And I said to myself that I would just roll with it, and in January,
I'll say no to every single job,
and I'll only be focusing on gradually weaning off.
And then just quit everything.
And that's the worst thing I've experienced.
But at the same time it was the best, because I was following a plan.
Weaning off something ...
what did that feel like for your body, in a physical sense?
I hallucinated a lot.
In January, February ...
I had insane cramps,
I slept, at best, two hours at night.
And there were nightmares all the way.
And my mother has some «funny» film clips where
I ask her to remove the ants that are crawling on my teeth.
«No Alexander, there are no ants.»
«Yes, come on mum, please!»
You thought you had ants on your teeth?
Yes.
Alexander, you mention your family.
You were born in Belarus.
How strong is the connection between
you guys who live in Oslo
and your family who live there,
because you still have family there, don't you?
Yes, yes, yes.
With it being so dramatic there, what kind of contact do you have?
That hasn't changed, because
I've always had a good relationship with my family down there.
And you should see my dad, it's very heart-warming ... I live with my dad and mum now ...
So every morning I can hear him playing accordion and piano on Skype, for his mother.
And sometimes I'll join.
It's very nice.
And they don't talk very much about politics and things like that.
And I've been encouraged, of course, to
say something out loud.
But it's easy to suddenly make the mistake of talking about something you don't know much about.
I feel that
as a known person
you should really familiarise yourself with a case,
if you're really, really good, you familiarise yourself with a case,
and you should voice your opinion, especially if it's useful.
Or, if you feel like you don't have time, you have to wait
until you've familiarised yourself with the case, before you talk about something you don't know anything about.
You maybe got burned a little as well, because I can remember that many years ago,
there was an image of you and Lukashenko, I think, the president ...
I wouldn't say that I got burned. At the time he had organised a concert, and
it would have been strange to say that I would come but that I wouldn't agree to a picture with the organiser.
So it's ...
I haven't gotten burned.
No, but you got told off quite a bit?
Yes, yes. But if I get burned every time I get told off, I'll become steaming hot in the end!
How did you experience him?
Shall we move on, perhaps?
You don't remember?
Yes, yes, yes.
But it's just that ... Even though this is
a show in Scandinavia,
it gets watched in
it's watched very closely in Eastern Europe as well.
And that's why I want to, again, as I've said,
wait until I've really familiarised myself with the case before I ...
When I see a police offiser
beat up a protestant in Minsk,
maybe it's just me that's built in a strange way, but
I don't immediately think politics, I think
«he shouldn't be allowed to be a police officer».
But when you don't
pick a side, in a way,
are you afraid of not being able to
travel there again?
I do have family there. Yes.
I think that they intentionally also maybe don't tell us about ...
They want to ...
I think that my grandmothers are very aware that I'm an artist.
And that the more I know, the more exposed I am.
Yes.
Alexander, it's a great pleasure having you with us again.
And we're getting in a few more guests, but you'll be with me here in Oslo.
Thank you! I look forward to it!
We're getting in more guests, and in the end, you'll be playing for us.
Alexander Rybak, ladies and gentlemen!